l'information a fait le tour des médias
ce week end guillaume pelletier est
désormais le nouveau porte parole d'eric
zemmour une annonce qui a fait grand
bruit dans la sphère politique notamment
chez les républicains ou le député du
loir-et-cher a été numéro 2 au niveau
local c'est l'incompréhension et la
déception chez ses électeurs florent
clavel s'est rendu à neung-sur-beuvron
ancien fief de l'élu
incompréhension déception et même de la
colère hors caméra voilà les sentiments
qui animent les habitants de
neung-sur-beuvron trois jours après
l'annoncé du ralliement de leur ancien
maire à eric zemmour est-ce qui vire à
l'extrême droite c'est pas je me les
explique pas pourquoi il a abandonné sa
famille politique d'ailleurs ça lui
reprocher non ces courriers au fil du
temps et moi je trouvais que c'était
devenu de plus en plus agressif c'est
devenu très souvent très critique et peu
positif zemmour me semble parfaitement
incarné ce genre de choses le mot de
trahison revient dans la bouche de
certains car si guillaume pelletier n'a
tenu les rênes de la commune que trois
ans l'homme était plutôt populaire du
moins au moment de son parachutage en
sologne aux municipales de 2014
60% des habitants avaient voté pour lui
et même 70 % aux législatives trois ans
plus tard attirant aussi à lui des
électeurs de gauche
aujourd'hui le constat est amer à
l'image de celui dressé par caroline de
bodinat un temps son adjointe elle n'a
ensuite cessé de le combattre
politiquement c'est juste quelqu'un qui
bouffe à tous les râteliers
c'est quelqu'un qui est
qui ne peut pas vivre sans faire le buzz
lui il ne gère des choses que par
rapport à lui même au delà des affinités
politiques évidentes est ce le besoin
permanent de mouvements et de
médiatisation qui ont poussé guillaume
pelletier à franchir le rubicon pour le
maire de neung-sur-beuvron et les
raisons de ce choix restent obscures lui
en tout cas la sueur si le nouveau
porte-parole du parti reconquête vient
le voir je ne donnerai pas mon
parrainage pour eric zemmour voilà ces
fermes c'est ma position est assez ferme
là dessus je suis apolitique je me suis
engagé en tant que tel auprès des
novillos du noir et de mon équipe
municipale
notre équipe est une équipe pas
politique je resterai sur cette position
et je ne donnerai mon parrainage
personne n'est pas eric zemmour et les
habitants de s'interroger aujourd'hui
sur l'avenir politique de leur ancien
maire et actuel député un avenir pour
beaucoup sans issue en tout cas avec
eric zemmour